Krylo quantum diagonalization or KQD for short refers to solving a matrix value
problem by projecting the matrix into a subspace prepared on a quantum computer consistent with the Kryof method a
powerful approach from classical linear algebra. Throughout this video we'll explore what the Kryoff method is useful
and how and when to implement it on quantum computers.
So what is the Kryoff method? Suppose we have a matrix H related to a scientific or business endeavor with n rows and n
columns. We're interested in the lowest igen value e 0 and the corresponding igen vector size 0. Let's define an
initial vector v which might be motivated by the structure of h or might be entirely random. The krylov subspace
of order r which we write k r is generated by acting with h on this
initial vector r minus one times adding the result of each subsequent h action
to the set of spanning vectors that is kr is the space spanned by the vectors v
hv h squ and so on. These vectors will not generally be orthogonal.
Classically, we often carry out an orthogonalization process very much like the Graham Schmidt procedure. You start
by normalizing the initial vector V and call the result V 0. Then for the next vector HV, you subtract off its
projection onto V 0 to make the two vectors orthogonal. You then normalize the result. You continue like this,
acting again with H and making the result orthogonal to all previously added vectors until you've built up R
orthonormalized vectors required to span your Rdimensional Kryof subspace.
Once you have this subspace, you project your matrix onto it and diagonalize the smaller projected matrix. There are
subtleties and extensions, but that is a Krylov method at its simplest level.
To get a better sense of how this works, let's look at a trivial example. If H is this matrix and V is chosen to be this
vector, then we would start by normalizing V. To generate the second vector in a Krylooff subspace, we act
once with H on our initial vector and then make that result orthogonal to V 0.
A little algebra yields this for V1.
This is not useful for such small matrices and would not typically stop at a kryof dimension of two. But if we were
to project H onto our new kryoff space K2, we would do this using a matrix V
which has a Kryof vector for each column and its transpose conjugate which has Kryoff vectors for rows. We would then
obtain this matrix.
This matrix technically has lower dimension than our original. Obviously, this reduction is not useful at this
scale. This method is intended for reducing matrices with many thousands or even millions of rows and columns down
to just a handful. So why are Krylov methods useful? It turns out that this simple prescription
of operator action is often the most efficient way to approach the lowest value state or ground state of a matrix
operator. Let's make this a bit more explicit though we'll leave a full proof to the accompanying text. We wish to
solve a problem of the form h acting on the vector x gives us some constant times the vector x. Let's start with a
guess of our igen vector x0. This is just an approximate solution. It has error which we call e 0. Now we want to
make an update of this guess which we'll call x1 which we hope improves our approximation. We can express this as
the original x0 plus some correction p 0 which is yet to be determined. We can
repeat this process iteratively adding more and more correction vectors pi.
Obviously we want our error to be reduced but it isn't just the state that we care about. We also care about the
action of h on that state. So the quantity we really want to minimize is the h norm of this error or the norm of
the action of h on this error.
Now we can see that this is an expression involving p 0 and we can ask ourselves what choices of p minimize
this h norm of the error most efficiently. From what space should we select the correction? Under certain
conditions such as when h is symmetric and positive definite, choosing the first r corrections from within kr turns
out to be optimal. In simpler terms, we need some way of preparing a good subspace onto which we
can project our Hamiltonian. And in many cases, the Krylooff subspace is the space spanned by the vectors of most
efficient corrections to our initial guess.
For a real proof, see the text accompanying this video.
Everything we've described so far can be done classically. So, how and when would we use a quantum computer?
For very large matrices, the Kryoff method can require long computing times and large amounts of memory. The time
required for matrix operation of H on V scales like N squared in the worst case.
And this is done for every vector we want in our subspace. The subspace dimension R is usually not a significant
fraction of N and often scales like log of N. So generating all vectors scales
like order N^2 log N.
Although there are other steps like orthogonalization, this is the dominant scaling to keep in mind.
Quantum computing allows us to change what attributes of the problem determine the scaling of the time and resources
required. Instead of dependence on matrix size n across the board, we'll see things like the number of shots and
the number of non-commuting poly terms that make up a Hamiltonian.
Let's explore how this works.
Recall that the operator that time evolves a quantum state is the exponential of iH over h bar. And it's
very common, especially in quantum computing, to drop the h bar from the notation.
One way of understanding and even realizing such an exponential function of an operator is to look at its foyer
series expansion. Note that this operation acting on some initial vector V yields a sum of terms